in Japan steigt die Angst vor einem
Angriff Chinas
ich kämpfe für den Frieden und die
Unabhängigkeit meines Landes sie rüsten
auf gegen den großen Feind
du bist in der chinesische Schiffe
kommen immer näher
das macht mir große Angst
dass die Spannungen eskalieren
es genügt nur ein kleiner Zwischenfall
um einen ganzen Krieg auszulösen ein
Kampf gegen die größte Flotte der Welt
für Japan von vornherein aussichtslos
[Musik]
wir sind im Süden Japans unterwegs auf
einer der nanzay-inseln auf amami ein
Taucher Paradies mit Traumstränden und
tropischen Temperaturen
amami steht auf der Liste des
Weltnaturerbes
mitten in die tiefgrüne Natur mischen
sich seit einer Weile diese grünen
Gebäude
einschmiegen sollen sie sich in die
friedliche insel-landschaft doch was auf
diesem Gelände trainiert wird ist Krieg
wir befinden uns auf einer Basis der
japanischen
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte und
bekommen hier selten Einblicke nur
wenige bekommen zu sehen wie sich Japan
auf einen möglichen Krieg vorbereitet
stolz wird uns der Fuhrpark präsentiert
viele Fahrzeuge Geräte und Waffen
nagelneu
neu ist für viele Soldaten auch das
Training mit diesen Flugabwehrraketen
geprobt wird ein Angriff Chinas
im Ernstfall müssen wir gleichzeitig mit
Angriffen aus der Luft vom Meer und vom
Land fertig werden und mit fertig werden
meine ich wenn ein feindliches
Kriegsschiff in unsere Hoheitsgewässer
eindringt dann feuern wir Raketen ab
darauf müssen wir vorbereitet sein
seit Monaten nehmen die Spannungen vor
Japans Küste zu
Russland Nordkorea China Japan sieht
sich von undemokratischen Staaten
umgeben Zentrum des Konflikts
China betrachtet Taiwan als abtrünnige
Provinz und droht mit einer Übernahme
notfalls auch mit Gewalt erst vor kurzem
probte die Volksbefreiungsarmee auf
offener See einen Angriff auf den
Inselstaat
Staatschef schießen bringen will bis
2035 eine Weltklasse Armee aufbauen
Propaganda bilder wie diese sollen im
Staatsfernsehen zeigen China ist auf
einem guten Weg dazu
sie rüstet das Militär massiv auf will
das Ausbauen zu einer Mauer aus Stahl
die japanischen landseeinseln werden im
Fall eines Angriffs Chinas auf Taiwan
die Frontlinie der Verteidigung der
westlichen Verbündeten auf fünf der
nannte Inseln hat die Regierung in Tokio
bereits Militärbasen errichten lassen in
Windeseile
der Stützpunkt Armani war vor wenigen
Jahren noch ein Golfplatz aufgekauft von
der Regierung umfunktioniert zu
Raketenbasis die knapp 600 Soldatinnen
und Soldaten hier trainieren auch
regelmäßig mit ihrem größten Verbündeten
den USA sie lernen neue Waffensysteme
kennen und üben neue Taktiken ein Ziel
China und seine Kriegsflotte abschrecken
wir sehen uns als eine große Gefahr dass
in unserer unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
ein großes Land versuchen will den
Status Quo eines anderen Landes zu
verändern es ist immerhin ein Land das
Raketen und Atomwaffen entwickelt hat
dieser Macht China setzt Japan nicht
weniger als eine Zeitenwende entgegen
nach mehr als 70 Jahren hat sie fismus
zum ersten Mal seit Jahrzehnten rüstet
auch Japan massiv auf im vergangenen
Dezember beschloss die Regierung in
Tokio der Verteidigungshaushalt soll
sich bis 2027 nahezu verdoppeln und
Japan will noch in diesem Jahr 400
Tomahawk Raketen von den USA kaufen
Reichweite dieser Marschflugkörper rund
1000 km
von den Stützpunkten auf den
landsee-inseln aus könnten diese Raketen
bis in die chinesische Metropole
Shanghai fliegen bislang war in Japan
gesetzlich nur eine Reichweite von 200
km erlaubt doch das ändert sich jetzt
Japans Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte
waren noch nie in Kampfhandlungen
verwickelt jetzt besitzen sie auch
Waffensysteme für Gegenschläge es ist
der radikalste Kurswechsel Japans seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
doch wird Peking sich von all dem
beeindrucken lassen und zurückschrecken
hieroformie yomura befürchtet das
Gegenteil auf seinem Auto steht der
Slogan wir sind gegen die gemeinsamen
Truppenübungen von Japan und den USA
damit fährt er über die Insel und
organisiert Protestveranstaltungen der
74-Jährige macht sich große Sorgen um
seine Heimat yumura baut hier schwarzen
Reis an nach einer Jahrhunderte alten
Tradition es ist sein Nebenerwerb in der
Rente früher war er Lehrer und hat die
Kinder auf arami unterrichtet
wenn der Konflikt rund um Taiwan
eskaliert dann werden die USA die
japanischen Streitkräfte als ihren
Schild benutzen
noch nicht welche Taktik sie genau für
den Kampf verwenden wollen
aber ich habe große Angst dass amami und
den nanse-inseln als ihr Schutzschild
herhalten müssen
die Lokalregierung habe den
Inselbewohnern gesagt die Soldaten seien
nach arami gekommen um die Einwohner von
Naturkatastrophen wie Taifunen
zugeschützen
doch jetzt erlebt der Farmer jeden Tag
wie Militärfahrzeuge durch die
friedlichen Inselstädtchen fahren wie
neue Truppen und neue Waffen hier
ankommen
er und seine Mitstreiterin Midori Jutz
zum Motto erzählen uns von ihrem sorgen
beide gehören einer Generation an die
unter den Nachwehen des letzten großen
Krieges des Zweiten Weltkriegs auf arami
aufgewachsen sind 8 Jahre lang war die
Insel damals von den USA besetzt
[Musik]
ich bin über 80 Jahre alt wurde in dem
Jahr geboren als der Zweite Weltkrieg
ausbrach ich erinnere mich an das Blut
vergießen und die Grausamkeit des
Krieges
ich weiß dass Krieg niemals gut ist und
es tut mir weh das heutzutage immer mehr
Menschen sagen wir müssen gewinnen koste
es was es wolle
Japan hat den Pazifismus in seiner
Verfassung verankert und sollte sich
heute auf sein Versprechen besinnen
Japan sollte die Welt darin anführen
endlich die blutige Vergangenheit hinter
sich zu lassen
sollten endlich verboten werden Japan
sollte zum Vorbild werden für den
Weltfrieden
viele auf der Insel stimmten ihm zu
erzählt der Farmer doch immer weniger
trauten sich das offen auszusprechen für
die militärische Aufrüstung
interpretierte die japanische Regierung
die Verfassung neu eine Abstimmung
darüber gab es nicht und deswegen fühlen
sich auch viele hier in der Bevölkerung
nicht mitgenommen
doch es scheint auch eine
Generationenfrage zu sein auf unserer
Reise treffen wir zahlreiche junge
Menschen die glauben was die japanische
Regierung seit Monaten gebetsmühlenartig
wiederholt das ein Krieg rund um Taiwan
immer wahrscheinlicher wird ein Krieg
der sich auch auf japanisches Gebiet
auswirken könnte
amami hat etwa 60.000 Einwohner bis zu
100.000 Touristen besuchen die Insel
jedes Jahr neben der Landwirtschaft ist
der Tourismus hier die
Haupteinnahmequelle
Strand finden wir einen Laden der
Schnorchel Touren in die Korallenriffe
anbietet dieses Paradies müsste bei
einem Angriff auf jeden Fall verteidigt
werden findet der Inhaber auch assano
Kyoto beobachtet mit Sorge dass sich die
Lage im Indopazifik zuspitzt
chinesische Schiffe kommen inzwischen
immer näher an unsere Insel heran das
ist schon beunruhigend das macht mir
große Angst
die Soldaten die jetzt auf amami
stationiert sind seien im willkommen
sagt er sie seien sogar gut fürs
Geschäft
in den Restaurants und Läden haben wir
jetzt mehr Kunden weil die
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte sie in
ihrer Freizeit besuchen das ist ein
guter Nebeneffekt der Militärbasis
Kyoto selbst will nicht kämpfen
renici dafür umso mehr damit zählt er
zur Mehrheit in Japan die die
militärische Aufrüstung befürwortet fast
zwei Drittel stimmten in einer
landesweiten Umfrage diesen Januar dafür
ici wurde auf amami geboren jetzt ist er
hier dem
panzerabwehrbataillon der
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte
beigetreten er will seine Heimat
verteidigen
schon als ich in der Highschool war habe
ich mir im Fernsehen Berichte über die
Arbeit der
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte
angeschaut sie arbeiten hart begeben
sich in Gefahr zum Wohle der japanischen
Bevölkerung es ist der beste unter
ehrenvollste Job überhaupt
seine Kameraden alles tun um China
abzuschrecken um den mächtigen Nachbarn
davon abzuhalten Taiwan anzugreifen die
ganze Region rüstet auf
Militärbasen der USA Südkoreas der
Philippinen Australiens und Japans ob es
ihnen gelingen wird einen Krieg zu
verhindern sie hoffen es
hier auf arami leben sie täglich mit der
Gefahr hier ist der Konflikt mit China
greifbar nach zwischen Traumstränden und
Truppenübungen
[Musik]